[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gipfel achtung
ihr habt so lange darauf gewartet und es
tut mir auch leid dass sie so lange
drauf warten musst sind was kann ich
warum ich dich dazu kam aber lammert
schon ist bei uns sehr beliebt also wenn
ich bei meiner mama bin die macht das
eigentlich immer oder ich mache halt
einfach selber und verteilen dass man in
der familie und mein rezept ist wirklich
sehr sehr einfach und total lecker und
ich zeige euch jetzt schritt für schritt
wie er das hinbekommt also keine panik
jeder kann nach man schon selber machen
ich habe direkt an mit dem teig und
dafür nehme ich mir hier ganz normales
mail typ 405 gibt es in eine schüssel
ich mache das jetzt mit den händen ich
gebe zu ich mache sonst nur mit der
küchenmaschine einfach aus
bequemlichkeit aber nicht jeder hat eine
und deswegen habe ich gedacht war wie
sympathisch ich bin ich denke ich zeige
euch das habe den himmel
und ich habe jetzt nicht alles dazu
gegeben weil wir müssen halt später
gucken wie viel mehr wir benötigen immer
so zwischen 470 und 500 gramm aber das
schreibe ich euch unten in die video
beschreibung da kommen jetzt die
flüssigen zutaten dazu milch wasser und
olivenöl
[Musik]
salz zucker und trockenhefe kommen auch
noch mit dazu und dann verbiete ich es
erst in der schüssel und dann circa vier
bis fünf minuten auf der arbeitsfläche
jetzt habe ich trockenhefe benutzt ihr
könnt auch frische hefe benutzen dann
müsst ihr vorab die frische hefe einfach
in der lauwarme milch richtig schön
einmal arbeiten das mit dem zucker
zusammen ich schreibe euch das aber ganz
genau in die video beschreibung so mein
tag ist eigentlich so weit fertig der
ist ja nicht trocken der darf auch nicht
zu trocken sein und jetzt nehme ich mir
mein olivenöl und gibt es in die
handinnenflächen und dann müssen wir das
rundherum einmal mit olivenöl benetzen
und eine stunde lang gehen lassen und
das olivenöl das ist dass palästina
kaltgepresst das ist unser eigenes
olivenöl das verlinkte ich euch
selbstverständlich in die infobox
[Musik]
sodann muss nur mal die zwischenzeit und
machen die aussagen herstellung aber das
hat echt hopping auch wenn sich das
komisch anhört aber es geht auch sehr
sehr einfach ich habe jetzt hier
hackfleisch oder gehacktes und dann
nicht die fettarme variante nehmen
sondern ganz normal die fertige variante
wenn man in einer großen schüssel geben
und da gehe ich jetzt schuldig und
lautstärke und da und da gebe ich jetzt
tomatenmark dazu so salz pfeffer und ich
nehme noch paprika flocken dann nämlich
die süßen wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr auch
chili oder irgendwas mit dazu
[Musik]
die zwiebeln dann richtig schön dazu
reiben richtig schön fein und
anschließend nehme ich mit peperoni ich
habe jetzt hier wie durch zufall drei
grüne und eine rote ihr könnt auch zur
hälfte rot grün oder nur grün ist
vollkommen egal habt ihr es mit einem
wiegemesser bearbeitet und dann werden
die so fein und dann sieht das mal
richtig richtig hübsch aus auch am ende
und das gebe ich jetzt mit dazu und dann
vertrete ich das auch wieder mit den
händen und heute verzichte ich auch mal
auf
handschuhe auf einweg handschuhe weil
ich einfach keine da habe auch
ja klar die hände sind sauber und jetzt
einfach hände rein und dann verkneten
die nächste wichtige zutat bei der
fleischmasse ist olivenöl das ist ganz
wichtig es gibt auch rezepte da kommt
dann da kommt dann tomate mit dazu aber
ich setze auf tomatenmark in verbindung
mit olivenöl es nämlich später schön
verstreichen und es schmeckt auch sehr
gut also einfach mit dazu geben und noch
mal eingenähten
[Musik]
die fleischmasse ist jetzt fertig und
mein tag ist auch aufgegangen so sieht
jetzt aus einmal aus der schüssel
rausnehmen und dann nehme ich mir so
teiglinge ungefähr 70 bis maximal 80
gramm dick
[Musik]
die arbeitsfläche jetzt mit mehl
bestäuben und den teig darin relativ
dünn ausrollen dann gebe ich ein
esslöffel von dem hackfleisch mit dazu
und das könnt ihr am besten mit dem
löffel rücken schön verstreichen da darf
wirklich nicht viel drauf und jetzt
nehme ich mir hier einen kuchen heber
weil ich muss es irgendwie in meine
fahne kriegen und dann nehme ich den
kuchen lieber beim nächsten werde ich
glaube ich erst mal das ausgebaute
teilstück drauf legen und dann mit
fleisch belegen stoppt das geht
einfacher
[Musik]
so drei bis vier minuten maximal fünf
jetzt in der pfanne mit geschlossenen
decke und da muss das so aussehen und
dann nehmt ihr das raus einmal rüber
unter die torten haube
[Musik]
so der nächste ist fertig und ich
schwanke immer so zwischen stufe 6 und
heizen ab und zu mal auf 7 auf jetzt
kommt er auch wieder unter die haube und
dieses mal umgedreht also immer fleisch
an fleisch
[Musik]
so mein letzter lahmacun ist jetzt
fertig und ich stapel die hier schon
fleißig und wenn ihr euch fragt warum
macht sie zu einem torten haube drüber
das hat mehrere gründe also
sieht außer gekippt hatte zum einen ist
es halt wichtig dass die weich bleiben
wenn ihr die knusprig möchte dann
verzichtet hier auf wenn ihr es
wahrhaben möchte unbedingt die torten
habe um drüber gehen warum geht jetzt
keinen lappen der lappen hat zu wenig
raum also hier in dem raum bildet sich
jetzt der ganze dunst manchmal kurz aus
hier und jetzt fertig und
dadurch bleiben die lammert uns schön
weich man kann sie später einrollen zum
einrollen was ein übergang brauchen wir
salat weil das ist so typisch und dafür
habe ich jetzt hier die folgenden zu
landwirte schon mal fein geschnippelt
und zwar habe ich hier rote zwiebeln
petersilie ganz typisch dann haben
hänger tomaten gurken tomaten und gurken
ganz typisch ist jetzt zu mag das kennt
ihr schon von mir das ist dass es sich
baum gehört eines meiner familie das
passt einfach auch zu jedem salat das
hat so dass schnitt so ein bisschen wie
pulverisierter
essig pulverisierte zitrone ich kann
sich ganz beschreiben könnte gerne mal
ausprobieren ich verlinke euch wie
gesagt alles in die infobox was ich da
jetzt auch noch dazu gäbe ist olivenöl
spiel so ein bisschen und natürlich salz
und dann kommt mein geheimtipp leute
meint erst noch gedreht mein geheimtipp
hallo
genommen
granatapfel zero probiert ist aus dieses
süß säuerliche es schmeckt so geil ich
muss jetzt aber war er schmeckt hier in
meinem granatapfel sirup sind keine
unnötigen zusätzlichen ich zeige euch
das mal in dem ich das einmal aus der
flasche wisse wie schön dickflüssig das
ist und genauso muss granatapfel sirups
sein und dann wenn ihr das ganze so wird
einfach noch ein bisschen zitronensaft
darüber wenn ihr mögt aber ich habe
richtig hunger ich habe glaube ich noch
nie so hungrig ein video gedreht aus den
ramadan du hast auch schon richtig
hunger
wo also ich muss mich erst mal reinhauen
leute ich muss erstmal die entziehen
machen wir druck haben sagt und dann
haben wir richtig rein ok ich
verabschiede mich von euch leute mit
euch ganz viel freude beim nachmachen
falls sie irgendwelche fragen habt hier
unten in die kommentare stellen ich
beantworte sie euch und ansonsten stehen
die ganz
[Musik]
andere sagt nach münchen kommt aus dem
arabischen
aber es ist so typisch türkisch es ist
doch mega typisch türkisch okay wir
können einmal darüber diskutieren
ansonsten die ganzen menge angaben
findet ihr unten der videos beschreibung
mit kümmel gequatscht und wir sehen uns
dann beim nächsten mal
gekickt und der
[Musik]